everyone Haley Joel Osment here today  we're going to teach you how to make a  paper airplane the dark Persian though  because it has a sharp tip don't make a  dirty joke there okay Oh first you start  off with a simple blank piece of paper  fold it in half then you're gonna fold  the corners straight to the middle then  you're gonna fold it in again  I'm the openers burning town they're  gonna fold it out Jimmy make it really  make it as even as possible you want to  keep the tip really sharp  don't make any dirty jokes don't so then  you're ready to soar I hope you like my  paper airplane tutorial if there are any  other tutorials you want me to teach  write in the comments below  no dirty things okay I can't do it  bye guys